[Music]
we're just talking to developers and
other interesting people using Wolfram
technology and really cool ways and I'm
sitting here with Kevin can you tell us
a little bit about what you do at
Wolfram and sure so I am a junior user
interface developer so I work in the
front-end team I mostly work on
dialogues so like in the new release
good good so mean intense like the
dialogue is the main thing I'm doing
right now some code cleanup because I'm
new so it gets me to learn about our
code base but otherwise I also get some
other fun projects that aren't exactly
just doing dialogues so here
I aimed myself to junior to have a
presentation so I'm actually just mostly
attending talks talking to some of the
other people attending just getting
their feedback on send mail cuz it was
presented and John pulls his talk so
hopefully you get some good feedback on
that so in my vast spare time I do
dabble in video game making very simple
things like I've actually given other
talks I like the summer school on just
video game design
what's nice about the Wolfram language
is you can bring in all these different
aspects very quickly like I don't have
to code and see if you it's a nice high
level language so I could just grab
images off the web so I'm not an artist
like I've learned very much so that game
designed by a single person is almost
insurmountable like props to those who
can do it
and for me it's like if I can grab a
sprite off of the web you know get a
MIDI file so I have some background
music it's so much easier than I have to
do this on my own so what are some of
the games that you created there was
like the first big one I did for the
summer school was flappy bird I kind of
resurrected that in the Wolfram language
and that actually led to a blog post
that I had a bit different version than
I had originally put on my community
page but I've span I've kind of made
things more complicated I went and
actually worked on Castlevania it was
released in 1986 so it was like the 25th
anniversary something like that I
thought I would take a stab at it and
then kind of like when you're designing
a house you want all the coolest
features in there and then you realize
how hard it is how you scaled back so I
wanted to do like the first like the
game and the Michael came able to do the
first stage it's like I'll just do the
the location outside the castle it was
like okay and then I'm just gonna do one
enemy type that's it so even though I
did scale back a lot of what my original
grand design was it was still a really
good learning project and I actually
give it credit for me getting a job in
the front end team nice so I started out
in tech support but with these games
that I developed I showed my ability to
work in the front end and so I had this
nice portfolio and so I made some noise
and one thing led to another so then I
joined their group
awesome so Castlevania do you I mean you
have a notebook here yeah I can show it
off so what is this
I guess this what is that first section
actually so I wanted to show so I have a
surface book here which is a Microsoft
device and I've got an Xbox controller
and I just wanted to show how easy it is
for the Wolfram language to connect to
external devices so in this example I've
just got a few manipulates so you can
see that as I move the joystick Oh
different controller states will update
and so it's just a nice way that you can
map different buttons and so with this
controller state function and again it
works really well because the driver is
already inside the laptop and so the
Wolfram language can detect the driver
and just use that CCM user and so even
just showing a basic example of a game
so I made basically a game designer so
like when mario maker came out it was
really interesting to actually make
side-scrolling games and so I made a
little basic thing don't just use the
d-pad and the a button to jump and
there's a double jump so you can
actually hit eight twice and so the goal
is to escape the maze no time I know I
can get out you just abort the
evaluation because it's living in the
front end I'll have to do is close the
cellar delete the cell and then it'll
actually stop running nice
so let's actually do some castlevania
I'll go ahead and take over for this not
saying that you couldn't do so
this one I actually created I didn't
want it to start right away because it's
a bit more complicated
so I'll actually replay its starting
from another state so like the demo you
just showed off I did include a double
jump in here even though it's not
required for this kind of game it's not
the original game is way clunky and so I
did it's running a little fast I
included a frames per second like global
variable this is very reminiscent of
like old computers which if you recall
like I grew up with a IBM 386 it had a
turbo button literally on the outside of
the computer tower and all games were
basically set to the cpu clock and so if
you turned on the turbo button some
games would run at ridiculous speeds and
so the front end works very similarly
I'm using dynamic behind the scenes and
so this game is running as fast as the
dynamic can basically reprocess the
screen and so what this leads to is
basically how fast your CPU is
determines how fast this game will run
and so it make it a little easier for
other people to pick this up I do have
this kind of global variable that you
can adjust for your CPU so where can
someone I guess get this lives in two
places I have a community post I also
have a github page where I store a lot
of my kind of funtime projects so I mean
I'm assuming you design games that you
like it's yeah it's not just a hobby not
quite a passion but it's game design so
when you're trying to teach someone
something if you don't have their
interest it's very hard for them to
learn the subject so if you want to get
into programming I think games are a
great way to do it even if that doesn't
become your profession
because it's a way to learn how to break
down a problem into smaller milestones
you your interest continues to hold
because you're involved and invested in
this kind of game so it's just it's a
great starting point for anyone who's
learning programming yeah so I mean so I
have been working on punch-out Mike
Tyson's punch-out for the original
Nintendo I've got most the animations
are the hardest
yeah these 8-bit graphics even Mario is
the ringleader
and but again scaling back from my grand
design I'm only gonna make one stage but
I'll maybe tweak the AI so it could be
harder or easier so you'll only fight
glass Joe which is the first character
but he might be pretty hard I mean you
could consider Castlevania a full-blown
game like there's a lot of games that
are considered simple like even flappy
bird you just tap the screen to try and
maximize your score I mean that's a
complete game yeah I guess I meant like
like all of the levels that would be
active but again I have my vast spare
time to deal with which I say
fantastically but yeah so that's why I
kind of stick with simple games like
even flappy bird I made and my first
prototype was maybe only six hours but I
kind of take that with a grain of salt
because I already knew the front-end
well enough to know how the pieces would
fit together
so aside from you know using games as
motivation for programming what other
advice do you have for people who are
interested in game design and just be
like a lot of people it's kind of like a
very I think the Unity game engine is
fantastic I haven't dabbled in it as
much as I probably would but because
Wolfram language has unity link you can
create assets because like I said if
you're a game designer of one the
artistry which includes all the assets I
mean I am just not talented in that way
you know I can sit in a dark room and
code for hours but if I can't draw to
save my life or compose you know right
she guessing so with unity you can
create a new deal Inc a whole bunch of
assets like geometry assets from within
the Wolfram language and then import
them very easily and then even through
the Unity sort of universe you can
actually purchase pre-made assets from
other people - including your game which
is pretty neat so I mean do you know
where you don't work on unity link know
that is Charles Poe's team and I know
Alec shuttle Bower gave a talk on that I
guess what are you most excited to see
as far as either with UI dialogue or
with game design what are you most
excited to see I'm really interested in
either mixed reality or just full
virtual reality seeing if we can somehow
do that because I know crossing my
fingers that video is on the way and if
we can do that with like a live stream
inside of Mathematica notebook
I mean yeah it's exciting well thanks
for chatting with me you're welcome
and stick around we'll have thanks